- I'm so nervous 'cause I feel like none of these
went with Black Panther.
^We're here to take this quiz.
^Which Avengers Infinity War character are you?
^- It's either gonna be Black Panther or Thor
^'cause those are my dudes.
^- I would want to get Captain America.
- I hate to break it to you,
but there can only be one Captain and that's me.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- I want Captain Americas physique.
Thor's superpower.
Iron Mans money.
Hulks strength.
- I'm going for all Black Panther.
So anything I think will be like, purple!
- I'm going purple but I'm going Thanos.
- Oh, okay!
- Thanos story line was incredible.
- Also, Thanos could be daddy, so.
I'm here for it.
^- Choose an Infinity stone.
- Soul is intense because you have to kill a loved one.
- I thought a lot about who would I throw down there
if I had to get rid of someone I loved.
- You have somebody you would kill for that?
- No, I'm not gonna kill anyone.
- I know, me either!
- Who in their right mind?
^- [Man] You came up with an answer?
- Yeah of course!
- Oh god.
- I would pick time because we just don't,
never have enough time.
- I would like to think I'm a soulful person.
- Who would you kill?
- Oh!
I would take out my ex!
I loved him at one point!
- I'm gonna go with time.
I feel like the time one is my jam.
Kind of always running late.
Just five, 10 minutes,
you know how you do with a stew sometimes?
- If someone were to ask me what kind of superpowers
do you want?
I would take time.
- I'm gonna go with time.
- Time, that's a good one.
I'm gonna do reality.
The way he was able to minipulate reality,
when he chopped everyone into cubes, do you remember that?
- That is a very cool one.
- That was insane.
^- What do you think people most admire about you?
- Would you admire any of these things about me?
- Confidence.
- Is it a casual confidence?
- What's the difference?
- Arrogance basically.
- Oh, no.
You're just confident, you're just confident.
- Awkward, but in a charming way.
Not awkward enough.
- Sure you are.
I'm just kidding.
- I'm not really that nice of a person.
- Or a genius.
- I was thinking I was a genius.
Maybe you're not a nice person!
- I'm a lovely person!
But I don't think we're out here solving--
- You gotta pick one for me.
- Ultra hot body.
Just do it. (laughs)
- People can depend on me to get things done.
Very organized.
I will task it out.
- I am not gonna pick that one.
I'm loving and compassionate.
- I'm gonna have to go with loving and compassionate.
I am told way too often that I am too nice of a person.
You are awkward but charming.
- I am very awkward but charming.
- Nothing I say here is positive to work for you!
- No, it's just funny how it's worded.
^- Choose a Star Wars character.
- I would say Luke, but he kinda acts like a little bitch.
He's kinda whiny, you know?
So go with Hans Solo.
- I gotta go with Hans Solo.
What more of a badass is there than Hans Solo?
- I'm gonna go with Rey, she's a bit of a rebel.
- I think you're more of a Finn.
I think you're courageous and you're heroic.
- Gas me up.
- BB-8 is your Star Wars character?
- He's my soulmate.
I can connect with him right now.
- Okay, I'm not here to judge, I'm not here to judge.
This is a judgment free zone.
- I'm kinda like a robot.
- Robot in a hot body, okay.
- I'm definitely Hans Solo.
I'm arrogant, I'm cocky at some points,
but then I'm foolish and stupid with my decisions.
- But you're a genius?
- No, I said I wasn't a genius.
- Which character would you most want to make out with?
- Black Widow, hands down.
I had the hugest Scarlett Johansson crush.
- Captain America, the beard.
I'm not even into facial hair at all,
but it work--
- Gamora's my jam.
I know she's green but I just feel like it'd
be interesting to talk about, you know what I mean?
Not only is she sexy, beautiful, but she can kick my ass.
Why does that do it for me?
I don't know, but it does!
- I guess I'm just gonna have to be a queen
and go with Black Panther.
For the culture.
Sorry Thor!
(Zach laughs)
^- What is your weakness?
- The first ones, I can be a bit too impulsive.
I'm just gonna impulsively pick that one.
- Tendency of being unfairly dismissive.
- I have an awful temper.
- Really?
- Yeah, I'm like the Hulk at work.
I keep it very, very to myself.
If you see my home, tons of holes in the wall.
No, I'm just kidding.
- I have trouble letting my guard down,
allowing myself to be vulnerable with people--
- Oh, that's like--
- Definitely my weakness.
- Yeah, that's you.
- I can also be impulsive when it comes to Amazon
because there's prime shipping.
^- Choose an X-Men character.
- Not even a challenge.
This has been my dude since day one.
Wolverine, let's be real.
- I'm gonna go with Mystique.
- Shape shifter.
- I would use the ability to prank a lot of people.
- You would just go around the office
and be turning into people.
- I would just mess with people.
As long as you're not hurting anybody,
you can have fun with it.
- Mystique, it's one of the coolest characters ever.
You can be whoever you want.
- I wanna pick Deadpool because I just love that character.
- Up until recently, I was always Wolverine.
But, in recent, Deadpool.
- Deadpool.
I have a very sarcastic personality.
- I'm also a romantic, which Deadpool is.
- Oh!
- What's up, girl?
(girl laughs)
^- What would be the first thing you'd do
^if you had an Infinity Gauntlet?
- Change the way I look!
- Change the way I look.
- Definitely that one.
(both laugh)
- I would have to go with make my number one crush
fall madly in love with me.
I did a weird look to the camera.
Cut that out.
(girl laughs)
- I think if it exists, it exists for a reason
and if I had been bestowed with it, I should use it.
But use it right!
- I'm gonna go with
eliminate poverty and economic inequality.
- Eliminate poverty and economic inequality.
How can you not pick that?
- It only makes sense to go with eliminate poverty--
- I agree.
- It's not something that someone could change like that.
But if you have the power to do it?
- Oh yeah.
^- We both got Captain America!
- But I really wanted Black Panther!
- I really wanted Thanos and now that i know that (laughs)
this is not a terrible thing to me.
^- You got Captain America.
^The good news is that you're a truly selfless
^and heroic person with a heart of gold.
The bad news is that you can be a little too stubborn
and have trouble letting go of the past.
I'm Captain America, I'll figure it out.
- I got Doctor Strange.
- We had very different answers too.
I got Doctor Strange.
^The good news is that you're incredibly intelligent
^and possess rare talent and insight.
The bad news is,
you're typically standoffish and kind of mean.
- Standoffish and mean?
- I'm not vibing on the bad news bit.
^- I got Doctor Strange.
^I know Doctor Strange is very gentle,
^very smart, he knows what he's talking about.
He knows what he's doing.
He's got the time stone.
I mean, hey, I'll take it.
- If you guys want to find out which Avengers Infinity
character you are, go and click on the link below
in the YouTube description and see if you can match up
and be a cap like me or a strange like him.
- What did other people get on this quiz?
- [Man] Other people got Captain America and Doctor Strange.
That's it.
- Nobody got Hulk, Black Widow, Spiderman?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Zach] Interesting.